У Німеччині поліція регулярно влаштовує рейди для перевірки водіїв на алкоголь,
зокрема далекобійників.
- Добрий вечір! Вживали алкоголь?
- Одне пиво.
- Одне пиво? Давайте зробимо тест. Ще-ще.
Цей далекобійник з Румунії таки не збрехав. Тест показав 0,3 проміле.
А в цього вже більше - 0,8 проміле. Йому далі їхати не можна.
У Німеччині дозволений рівень алкоголю в крові водія - не більше 0,5 проміле.
Фактично можна випити півлітровий бокал пива або келих вина і потім сісти за кермо.
Втім, на практиці поліція радить не перевищувати рівень 0,3 проміле,
адже в разі аварії або порушення правил дорожнього руху
алкоголь зараховується як обтяжуюча обставина.
При цьому водіям до 21 року, а також тим, хто отримав права менше двох років тому,
сідати за кермо після вживання спиртних напоїв взагалі заборонено.
Пити і потім сідати за кермо у Німеччині дорого.
За певних обставин оштрафувати можуть, навіть якщо у крові і менше 0,5 проміле,
коли, приміром, водій себе неадекватно поводить під час руху
або у спілкуванні з поліцейськими.
Мінімальний штраф у такому разі - 250 євро та один штрафний бал.
Водій, який перевищив допустиму норму спиртного 0,5 проміле,
сплачує штраф вже 500 євро,
отримує два штрафних пункти, а також на один місяць позбавляється водійського посвідчення.
Така ж санкція і за керування автомобілем під впливом наркотиків.
Якщо ж водія спіймають п'яним або під дією наркотиків повторно,
це вже 1000 євро штрафу, 2 штрафні бали і позбавлення прав на три місяці.
Водійські права можуть забрати і у велосипедиста,
якщо той крутив педалі напідпитку.
Якщо ж вміст алкоголю в крові водія більше 1,1 проміле,
це вже класифікується як кримінальний злочин.
Вважається, що водій, який досяг цієї стадії сп'яніння, вже не в змозі керувати автівкою.
Якщо ж водій, який перебував під дією алкоголю чи наркотиків, вчинив ДТП і є жертви,
наслідки будуть ще серйознішими.
Міру покарання визначає суд залежно від обставин аварії.
Це може бути не лише штраф, а й багаторічне ув'язнення і, звісно,
позбавлення посвідчення водія.
Крім того, винуватець інциденту зобов'язаний виплатити компенсації постраждалим.
Залежно від обставин ДТП, страхова компанія, клієнтом якої є порушник,
може відмовитися від відшкодування збитків.
У такому випадку водій це має зробити сам.
Загалом у Німеччині карають любителів надмірної дози пива чи шнапсу
грошовими штрафами та штрафними балами, а також, залежно від серйозності порушення,
можуть тимчасово заборонити керувати авто або позбавити посвідчення водія.
При цьому штрафні бали гасяться нешвидко.
Штраф в 1 бал - через два з половиною роки, 2 бали - через 5 років, 3 бали - через 10 років.
Коли накопичується 8 балів, посвідчення водія вилучається.
Тоді доведеться робити нове, а це дорого і складно,
особливо якщо відправлять на проходження медично-психологічного обстеження,
яке в народі називають "тестом для ідіотів".
Разом із сеансами у психолога та іншими витратами загальна вартість
може перевищити тисячу євро, а іноді і дві.
У Німеччині поради і тренінги, як пройти цей тест,
вже стали цілою індустрією з безліччю рекламних роликів в інтернеті.
Щорічно це обстеження проходить близько 90 тисяч водіїв,
включаючи тих, кого позбавляють прав на місці
- приміром, після скоєння ДТП у стані сильного сп'яніння.
При цьому майже половина водіїв не складають успішно "тест для ідіотів".
Крім того, відповідальне відомство може вимагати перескласти іспити з водіння і теорію.